c'était il y a à nantes
l'ouragan katrina frappait la louisiane
provoquant la mort d'au moins 1500
personnes à la nouvelle orléans
seule la moitié des habitants est revenu
les difficultés rencontrées chaque jour
sont nombreuses peu d'écoles par exemple
ont rouvertes mais aussi peu d'hôpitaux
le système de santé publique se trouve
au point mort tandis que les médecins
privés sont débordés le reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux plus une gilbert yvon
boude
c'était le navire amiral du système de
santé publique en louisiane 500 lits des
milliers de salariés 150000 admission
aux urgences chaque année tout cela
balayé en une nuit par catherine à
l'hôpital de la charité n'a jamais
rouvert
il était le seul à offrir aux plus
pauvres sans assurance privée des soins
de qualité dans ce quartier épargné par
l'inondation kevin fut l'un des rares à
rester pour soigner les victimes de
katrina
il fut aussi l'un des premiers à rouvrir
son cabinet après l'ouragan
et tant pis pour les bénéfices ont fait
tout ce qu'on peut pour rendre abordable
suivi des grossesses qui a de toute
évidence une importance primordiale
on est obligé de tâtonner en quelque
sorte de trouver différents moyen de
s'arranger avec les laboratoires
l'analyse notamment pour qu'ils nous
accordent des réductions certaine ces
patients je les reçois gratuitement à
question pour lui de refuser cette
patiente guatémaltèque enceinte de 18
semaines sans couverture sociale
elle explique que le dispensaire public
où elle s'est présentée en banlieue
refuse toutes les nouvelles patientes
faute de médecins
kevin lui pratique 12 accouchements par
semaine c'est quatre fois plus qu'avant
le plus dur c'est de trouver des lits en
maternité il jongle entre trois hôpitaux
contre une douzaine avant katrina
ce n'est pas que les lyssois tous
occupés mais il n'y a pas assez
d'infirmières
et si on manque d'infirmières on ne peut
pas ouvrir un celi
le fond du problème c'est le manque de
logements pour que les gens sont
réinstallés en ville on aurait alors
suffisamment personnel même influence
dans cette clinique prises et qui
multiplient elles aussi les
consultations gratuites faute d'adressé
fixe à fournir aux services sociaux
des dizaines de familles sinistrées ne
reçoivent plus l'aide médicale d'état à
laquelle elles ont droit
mais encore faut-il obtenir un rendez
vous la nouvelle orléans a perdu 60% de
ses médecins et notamment des
spécialistes en particulier le nombre de
psychiatres s'est effondré et c'est eux
dont on a le plus besoin ce parce que
tous ces gens à la nouvelle orléans ont
subi une catastrophe naturelle majeure
il souffre du syndrome de stress post
traumatique
ils ont des problèmes de comportement
des dépressions il ya beaucoup de
suicides ce dispensaire installées à la
hâte dans un ancien grand magasin c'est
tout ce qu'il reste de l'hôpital public
et tant pis pour les blessés par balles
ou les accidentés de la route
il n'y a plus de service d'urgences
vitales à la nouvelle orléans